hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have comic book
movies are all the rage aren't they from
Iron Man to spider-man and so forth
comic books have become huge box-office
gold this isn't the first time comic
books sold movie tickets film series
like Superman Batman and the crow are
all big hits that brought in big bugs in
the past but in the mid-90s the
superhero film started to die out and
would take almost a decade to get
rolling again well a lot of bad movies
were made one in particular many people
declared at the time the actual death of
the comic book movie and who better to
cut off the head of a successful
industry than the master of cinematic
blandness Shaquille O'Neal this is Steve
you'd think after Kazaam Shaquille
O'Neal would have learned his lesson to
leave acting too well actors but he
tried one last attempt to get hit with
the youngsters by playing a DC superhero
huh give him some credit though he's
tall so why is this dump declared so
horribly bad let's get this over with
and find out so we start off in what I
assume is the Hundred Acre Wood where
military experts seems to be reenacting
the opening too short sir unfortunately
our hero is far more robotic and tone it
Shaquille O'Neal playing army soldier
John Henry irons nice shootin Johnny
thanks Sparky my god he's still acting
like he's posing for our commercial
thanks porky so Shaq it turns out he's
an inventor creating high-tech laser
guns protective armor for his team and
just the cutest little handshake with
his partner Sparky this is gonna be an
army of fun but one soldier played by
Judd Nelson wants to show off exactly
what the gun can really do so he puts it
at the highest setting resulting in a
slow shot
apparently when you put at the highest
setting it results in the I am rubber
you are glue of it
this results in Sparkie getting crushed
by a pretty bouncy piece of concrete
chef's tries to help her out but
unfortunately styrofoam walls are his
only weakness you know the power of
styrofoam
oh uh anyway on Night Court burg did it
sir Thank You lieutenant that's all so
Nelson is dismissed from the Army a
Shack tries to figure out what should be
done with the incredible firepower in
their hands we can't turn our backs on
this kind of potential firepower maybe
you can't but after what happened to
sparks I can sir you know I'm running
out of things to say about shaquille
o'neal's acting Frankenstein isn't as
stiff because of what the guns did to
Sparky check decides he wants to go back
home well Nelson decides he wants to
sell his high-tech guns to evil so who
does he find to be the leader of the
underground crime scene none other than
an arcade game manufacturer of course
but I understand you're still selling
hot weapons I'm a legitimate businessman
how would you like to help me deal the
next generation of super weapons Wow
bender really did turn into a psycho
after Breakfast Club give me a little
seed money for the prototypes I'll do a
little advertising and we'll be partners
and I'm only offering this because you
remind me of my cocker spaniel I have a
real soft spot for those dogs so she
goes back home which I swear is the
house from Bob as he gets reacquainted
with his grandma and very happy to see
you why are we whispering it's told to
be a souffle Schwimmer you come storming
in we're talking softly because it all
upset the souffle how am I ever supposed
to master the art of French cooking when
you keep crashing in here like James
Brown I feel good
nananana so just to recap armed weapons
souffles and crazy grandmas I think
we're in for a wild ride it's supposed
to be our light and fluffy and full of
air you know like your head oh and she
also lives with some kid who I guess is
his son nephew I don't know it doesn't
explain very well now you mean stuff hey
why are you playing I got all kind of
crazy honey sweating me one of my homies
snagged me down to work at a place
called antastic but with this town me I
can make mad cream be mad Pass
can somebody get a dictionary it's like
a Chris Tucker with translated by Eddie
Griffin so we cut back to Nelson who
seems to be transporting the laser gun
for regular arcade games jeez maybe
video games do induce violence they give
it to a group of gang members who are
told to test it out by robbing a bank
change you gotcha all my guys are
filming a shampoo B I'm out of here
you know for people who don't want to
get caught they sure do make a shitload
of noise shut up
but it's okay because shag is riding
with some random cop person who will
never see again and she's called in to
stop the bank robbery while I'm doing
hey leave this shit do download to me
kid so as they write to the scene the
robbers are being bought off by probably
the prettiest guy to ever hold a gun oh
babe a needle brute as the situation
gets more heated everybody proceeds to
get out of the car except for the cop
hello officers down at 22 1816 we got a
big drop whenever this is the fact that
officers are bound already indicate that
there's a big problem
officers down we got a big problem here
I do not care for the way that this
series of events is unraveling no not at
all
so the thugs use their weapons again
then wouldn't you know it the cop in the
car gets injured gee if only she did oh
I don't know anything
it's on now
yeah guess maybe now you talk about a
incredibly harsh tone in my voice mmm
I'm angry you think you're going to get
away from me but you're not because it's
on a gate nah
gates can't hold me actually one at all
well that just magnifies the amount of
honest that's going on right now did I
mention its own its own so get it Shea's
scene between the gang members Shack as
they run back and forth between an
onslaught of slow-moving free trades
you
I'm sorry who thought this would be an
exciting idea people and very
slow-moving freight train the boredom
really just leaps off the screen doesn't
it
get this isn't an action movie it's a
game of Frogger so chefs left behind as
it looks like the little hoodlum escapes
and oh okay I get your chamomile cantata
work timber will you father you gonna
find my fist in your mouth
ash a kid shot to as the gang members
get away the shack is gonna take this
sitting down for he partakes in what I
like to call talking through your teeth
monologues I had it in my hand sir sonic
illuminator I plan what does that make
what the hell are they I'm so angry I
just got my jaw wired shut
it's a common side effect with a Shaq
tag meanwhile at pirate leather bar the
gang members celebrate their victory as
they see themselves mentioned on the
news the police have no clues as to the
perpetrators of this amazing hydrogen
you know he's got to be the dumbest
criminals in movie history yeah that's
us everybody we robbed that Bank we
brought that bag hey you go tell those
cops over there that be so jealous so
she comes in and locates the not exactly
hard to identify robbers just wanna know
where your boy got their weapon from oh
yeah well you know what I'd like to know
that too where'd you get the weapon from
don't make me use a curse word by the
way what bar just advertises beer that's
pretty generic isn't it oh yeah I've
always been a fan of beer beer it's
almost as good as burger burgers so he
doesn't get any answers and leaves the
bar to make things worse as Pal Sparky
got transferred to a Veterans Hospital
where apparently she's not very happy oh
man I got a do drama now must be awful
for you to imagine how you feel
no no you can't alright
I can't I'm sorry
there was a superhero in this movie
right uh 37 minutes ago I think the
better whisper about going out to fight
crime
yeah I'd be a big help on the streets
are you gonna do just sit here and look
out the filthy windows to be more
entertaining than watching this piece of
crap Oh human the window Oh Gary I can't
girl you out here what are you doing no
this is Sparks sometimes you don't get a
choice about things this here's a prime
example of shit happening and this is a
prime example of eyebrow spasms so he
carry Sparky out of the hospital as the
other vets applauded why I really don't
know maybe carrying wheelchairs just
excited this is even more exciting that
I tie that day with my keys and burn my
own thanks so Jan cater to a junkyard
where apparently he put a crime lab
together uh yeah forgot to show us that
scene Johnny what exactly am I supposed
to be doing here the same thing you did
an army we make our own kind of weapon
to take out the ones in the streets
because that's the solution get rid of
guns by creating even more guns stop
it's gonna take a lot more than that
just make me a list darlin I don't just
stand there beefcake yeah what did they
do to you man how did you go from shaft
to shit slam bam thank you ma'am
some other who's the private dick his
film career just
yeah so while working on crying webby
stuff sparky falls off her wheelchair is
unable to get back up
wait this ought to be funny
see I told you this is hilarious yes
well our work here is done
we did absolutely nothing hell is easy
so progress finally starts to happen at
Shaquille O'Neal's Playhouse as our team
builds all sorts of gadgets and even a
metal suit Sparky even creates an audio
device so they can hear one another how
do you read not well I said yes to this
kryptonite what is this man named John
Henry's just gotta have a handle well I
did the metal work especially like the
shaft there might get a little dangerous
I laugh at danger boogie around danger
like a Soul Train dance oh stop god damn
it I'm supposed to be a sex machine all
the chicks like that so Shaq finally
puts on the superhero suit and rides off
into the night to fight crime
Just Giving their stuff back we won't
have a problem
ain't got no problem
oh yes you do okay okay where's the
hidden camera by the way is it me oh is
this a very rubbery metal mask I think
this belongs to you
thank you
you'll be cool enough really an
escalator can't flies they use an
escalator do not fear I shall continue
to stop crime in the second floor
clothing Department damn homie
what the hell is that oh hey no angry
Joe is in this movie now put the gun
down and there won't be any trouble
oh it's hammer time huh let it what's
green a get hammered go out of style
actually you may notice that there's a
lot of lines taken from other movies in
this film Hotel easy being green good
too old for this
hold on the Internet Movie Database may
still have some other catchphrases that
nobody uses anymore
let's get jugu with it so he gets pulled
over by the cops because he'll you need
a reason
damn he's very unimpressive Lee getting
away damn boom this is the most
unimpressive superhero I've ever seen
slow and steady wins the race so he
jumps off the building and falls into
the garbage where he belongs
thankfully he just happened to put his
bike right next to that particular
dumpster as the outruns the cops and
makes it to his quote-unquote shack
where that's uncle bun go the Batcave
we've stolen from just about every other
superhero clich so yeah why not so I
guess they consider tonight a success if
you count stopping two criminals and
costing thousands of dollars in property
damage a success Sparky I don't know
what I'd do without you
meanwhile Nelson and the head gangster
beat in a public place so that they
don't draw attention to themselves yeah
because I would never take a second
glance at these two clowns would I never
underestimate your enemy and keep your
gold out of sight eat the hot dog don't
be one this is why they had to steal
their line from other movies because we
have a normal dialogue it's pretty day
so steel goes looking for more criminals
to fight it yeah this image really
strikes the fears on the hearts of men a
dog and out-of-work actor and a
muscle-bound light pole in an ice-cream
truck there's like birthday entertainers
but the laser gun gang is still on the
loose as they play the hold of yet
another Bank
haha
so they break into the place and it's
you'd imagine they never shut the hell
up
but sir blacks a lot comes along to save
the day unfortunately though the amount
of laser guns are too powerful for him
to defeat Wow this year away so he
visits his grandma's house later with oh
if it kills me bad and they're building
a much better story Shh but the souffle
of silence is broken by the entry of
cops to arrest Shaq under suspicion of
being a crummy action star yeah he
definitely fits the description to be
the man they call steal I gotta say this
movie has great suspense like will she
ever finished the souffle meanwhile
Nelson is getting ready to auction off
all his weapons to all the evil
organizations of the world but just how
is he gonna do it in this day and age
there's only one way the Internet
damn right we can pick up all kinds of
good crap not just porn oh oh tell me
more about this internet do you think
it'll ever catch on so through a long
uninteresting set of events Sparky gets
deal on to jail just in time for her to
get captured herself still tries to make
it to Nelsons headquarters where he
thinks she's being held when suddenly
okay this is the worst superhero ever he
just falls and gets shot at more of that
please so please welcome mr. warm and
fuzzy himself so they bring out Sparky
displayed the weapons and continue on
with their evil auction no gentlemen
here's the deal I can supply you with
weapons like these Oh you're under
arrest but unfortunately these weapons
are highly sophisticated can you say
guys will be used against you in the
course of all maintenance um yeah you
got a right to an attorney
this isn't really about money if you
cannot afford an attorney should I get
up you won't power anyone no now there's
an idea okay oh just stay down here that
you gentlemen think about this do you
really want to be the only ones without
my kind
to firepower my hammers got more juice
than that I find that hard to believe
I'll let my hammer speak for itself just
hit it right there on the bottom
don't turn the red switch don't point it
to yourself don't pull the trigger don't
fall to the ground wa bloody corpse of
course steel tricks the guy a sparky
tries to hell holy shit back it okay
obviously this chick should've been a
superhero the whole time better tools
better character better backstory
something went horribly wrong in
development that's right fire some more
because it works so well in the past so
somehow that annoyed you from before
ends up in the mix as one of the thugs
locks them in a room and frozen grenade
there's no way out
we quit
I never made these okay Binda knees okay
grenades do not take this long to
explode you can't perform an entire
comedy routine while the explosion waits
quietly in this scene was the least
thing realistic it'd be like I never
made these okay
bending knees now to the film's credit
the scene does lead to one very funny
reaction that's a little fine
so they defeat the bad guys deal walks
away without getting caught and all the
weapons are destroyed but one crucial
piece of information still remains did
grandma ever perfect the souffle
well done grandma well done now sure
will be a much better actor than how I
got paid my next movie
so how bad is still really bad people
say this killed the comic book movie for
a while well I can see why this was just
an attempt to give someone who shouldn't
have a movie career a movie career so
they figure giving this guy a
lesser-known DC comic character would
certainly be the way to go well then
look at the bright side at least he
didn't play Wonder Woman and yes I'm
gonna spin that image I'm going to start
a fair guy remember it's hot let it off
you're a nightmare
No